okay let's talk about the casting first
of all because your adult counterpart
pretty uncanny this whole movie is crazy
I mean did you spend bonding time with
him when did you meet him what do you
think I met her at the table read and
strength about super super cool weird
guy super weird like that's what we
found in common I brought up the bat I
think cusps super weird super cool and
he matched the attributes of Eddie so on
point yeah we're gonna ask you Shazam
cuz it's all I've been able to think
about for the past year Shazam Chi
what's happening it's only happening
definitely happening we know that Adam
Brody is Freddy Freeman's kind of adult
counterpart are you excited to maybe
explore a little more of that
relationship
I'd love to explore this suit if you
knew what I mean actually I don't even
know what I mean I haven't read the
script yet but yeah for sure there the
whole Captain Marvel jr. thing yeah like
I cannot say anything I will get in
walking up in ice with a I'm always
there's rumors that a sure angel might
play Prince Erik what do you think of it
oh my god he would knock out of the park
he would knock out of the park there's
rumors of that it's awesome that's
amazing good for him he totally would
[Music]